[Music]
I'm Roberto Ferrari I'm the curator of
art properties based in Avery
architectural and Fine Arts Library here
at Columbia University every couple of
years we try to do a round-robin of
various sculptures to do some
conservation and cleaning we have a
couple of sculptures that are being done
the most significant of course is alma
mater alma mater is the heart of this
university and it's a bronze statue but
she was gilded so literally the statue
was gold when you want to do care and
conservation you don't want to
necessarily and always bring everything
back to its origin sometimes the history
and the life line of a work of art is is
just as important as the original
context in which it appeared all of the
roofs here at Columbia for instance have
that patina green whereas originally
they were a copper color but the copper
just changes and oxidizes over time in
addition to alma mater we have a couple
of other works that are being done
including some of our relief sculptures
which probably have not had as much
attention in recent years the first
sculpture that was done is the Battle of
Harlem Heights which is lecture Leeloo
kated on Broadway near the earl hall
gate we're thrilled to be able to see
this get some refurbishment it's and
cleaning and conservation and relaxing
it's really about just trying to keep it
actively clean conserve and preserve it
for future generations to enjoy
[Music]